all right welcome ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls we are live on YouTube
and I am joined today by Nancy Muir
Ellie I'm so happy to be here
Nancy is an entomologist so she studies
bugs and she has a very very interesting
story she's not a normal entomologist
and she's going to talk a little bit
about that today and while she
introduces herself super briefly I'm
going to go in the other room and turn
the sound off on my computer because I
can hear it right now and that's going
to be a problem while we're broadcasting
so I will be back in one second
Nancy just tell them who you are okay so
for those of you who may have seen
John's channel before and he I guess
it's real it mentions me but my name is
Nancy Morelli and I am entomologist wish
Nissan I study bugs and I'm currently
living in the Ecuadorian I would like
I'm literally living in Ecuador but I
was living in the Ecuadorian cloud
forest for about two years so that's
kind of like my backstory I have a
master's degree in entomology from the
University of Georgia and right now in
Ecuador I'm doing like cloud forest and
insects and ecology tours yeah you were
working on some research over there are
you still doing that I'm actually not
doing research anymore because mainly
like so if you do research you kind of
just like really really focus in
research with a little bit of um but
there's like a little bit of outreach
and stuff on the side but I decided to
go like full outreach so that's that's
kind of where my tours come from it's
like I love bugs so much I love that
or so much like you can see amazing
things here everyone sucks for birds
don't care about insects but I'm like
you do care about insights they're
beautiful come with me and like see this
whole hidden world that's here so I I
went like this weird full time like
science education public outreach like
tourism route yeah yeah and and I
actually went on a tour with you I'm
gonna share my screen because I've got
some photos to show ya before you start
your presentation here share so Nancy
and I met what year was it was it like
somewhere I think it wasn't you
graduated so this is us the first day we
met and we did a presentation together
in Athens Georgia about chemicals so I
was I was working here's Chris he's the
guy that hooked us up with the speaking
event together so Chris works for the
Center for chemical evolution Chris
Chris Pearson Parsons and he he hired me
to do some animations for the center and
some speaking events for the center so I
was doing a speech on the origin of life
so the chemical origins of life and you
did your speech on chemical defenses and
insects so it was a really cool little
evening yeah yeah and then last year you
took us on a tour me and my buddies on a
tour of Ecuador and it was awesome so
this is us this is what city was this
again that little town
test out that eco-lodge I actually
really loved it and now I work with them
specifically yeah it's a beautiful
little town
and that's where they had they have a
butterfly farm what was that about that
was what do they do with those
butterflies there yeah so the owner
Rosie she's really awesome she's really
involved in conservation so half of the
butterflies stay in the garden for
rearing and showing the public and
getting people interested in bugs and
butterflies and stuff and then the other
half of the butterflies are re-released
everything that is in that butterfly
garden is um is specifically from mindo
and also from the cloud forest so
everything that she she releases belongs
in that area so it's like a dual
education and conservation project
that's really cool yeah yeah it's really
neat I mean people love butterflies and
people like to you know capture them in
the wild and keep them you know let it
put them into their collections and
stuff so it's really cool that they have
a farm right there in the actual forest
where they come from because so we you
know we went to this little butterfly
farm which was awesome but then just
just walking outside of our hotel there
was so much this is right outside of our
hotel at nighttime there was a they put
up a light for us and a little tarp
which would attract a bunch of insects
and we found all kinds of cool bugs this
walking stick on my head here but I mean
seriously was we tried to go on a hike
one day and just getting right outside
the door there were so many amazing
insects to see and birds to see that you
know it took us forever to go ten feet
you know because you make it about
thirty feet in about three hours yeah
and I think this is amazing I don't know
of anyone else who's doing insect tours
anywhere is this a thing not really
there's a couple people
as defined degrees and he was an insect
tourism Kinema and in Cambodia but right
now he's actually researching ants and I
have friend Nikki Bay who does amazing
photography you should look him up and
he does like a macro photography
workshop sometimes in Singapore about
bugs and then and then Phil Taurus does
like a trip to Peru once a year and
there's this thing called bug shot which
is I'm not going to talk a big workshop
that I'm actually working I think and I
put over this year um and that's it is
kind of everything that could count I
think that's all of them all of them
yeah it's crazy it's crazy how how small
it's crazy that no one's doing this
because doing these doing this was it
was absolutely amazing I mean if I had
gone to Ecuador and didn't have someone
like you around I would have been
terrified about all the insects today I
don't know what's poisonous and what's
not but you showed us which ones are so
safe you can put them on your face and I
mean there's it's just this huge world
beautiful world to explore that almost
everybody ignores and so I'm really
excited that you're doing this I mean
you're you're in Ecuador which is where
a lot of people go because they're
interested in biology they want to go
see the Galapagos Islands and learn
about Darwin and stuff and this is like
yeah if anyone is going down there to go
to the Galapagos Islands and learn about
evolution
you should also connect with Nancy
during your trip do you do help book
Galapagos I mean because you book tours
for people I do I have a friend who
Tuesday specifically Galapagos and I
refer everyone to my friend
mmm Morgan and she she like in the note
with all the boats and tour agencies and
hotels and everything so when people
need a book that Galapagos I
specifically referenced up to her and
because she had all the insider info now
like as near like mainland portals don't
get right right so anyway I did a
presentation on metamorphosis a couple
weeks ago and a lot of people had
questions about that and so Nancy being
an expert in all things
bugs is here by the way you can follow
her by googling SCI bugs you are SCI
bugs so s CI bugs and and that's where
you can they get hold you on Facebook
that's how they get a get booked a tour
with you and stuff right yeah so
basically how that works is you in a
tour and then I send you a survey it
basically asks you how long you plan on
touring with me how long you're planning
on being in the country like what areas
are interested in visiting what types of
like hotels and accommodations you like
what kind of activities you like and
with all of that information I build you
a personalized customized tour so I
think that's what sets me apart from a
lot of like even the other insect tours
is that it people are like oh I'm doing
an insect or this is what it is take it
or leave it
but if you message me like I
specifically book something that aligns
with your interest and your timeline
yeah and like anything when you are like
yeah I'm in Ecuador for three days I'm
like excuse me yeah yeah so let me tell
a story real quick before you get into
your presentation here one thing real
quick too is we've got the live chat
going and if you guys have questions
while Nancy is doing her presentation I
will be watching the live
like a hawk so we can hopefully get all
the questions in there and then of
course if you do a suit check question
you know we're guaranteed to find it and
read it we got one super chat already
today from Jay who just says thanks mr.
Perry and so make sure to put in all
your questions down here I am going to
be talking to today about just actually
really briefly about in vitro evolution
experiments I was going to be doing that
presentation today but Nancy got ahold
of me and and we're like well we should
we should talk about metamorphosis we
should answer people's questions that
they had from a couple weeks ago and
since she's here we're gonna be mostly
talking about that but the just one
thing before she starts the presentation
my my am I had three days in Ecuador it
was just a random thing about eeeh Mayan
got plane tickets and they were super
cheap it was just a weird thing with the
airlines where they had a really cheap
plane tickets to Ecuador but you could
only it was it was within a three-day
window so we could only be there for
three days if we wanted to get this
super cheap deal it was like $300 for a
flight down there and back which is
amazing so we did it and I just I was
like Nancy what can we do in three days
and she seriously it felt like I was
there for me I did what you normally do
and like several weeks because she just
filled every day with awesome stuff I
got to see amazing things we even went
to there's my buddy Isaiah here he's the
one that hooked us up with the plane
tickets and then yeah we even went to
the equator you know here's Nancy and I
at the equator and it was a lot of fun
it was it was amazing we had night tours
night hikes we did yeah we did the cloud
forest we even did I don't have any
photos in a slideshow here but we did a
bunch of stuff in the city as well and
in Quito which is a huge awesome city
beautiful city really old buildings so
yeah it was amazing
but without further ado what's uh let's
let's do the deep dive into
metamorphosis all right one thing that I
because people ask me all the time why I
love I could work so much and one of my
first times here someone was asking like
I was in a taxi and I asked them like
what what do you love about Ecuador as a
local and he was like I love the fact
that you can have breakfast on the coast
you can eat lunch in the Andean
mountains and you kind of dinner in the
Amazon and that is true you have to
start at 6 a.m. and you'd have dinner at
8 p.m. but you could literally do all of
that in a day it would be stressful but
you could add like just that idea that
you can change ecosystems in that
drastically in eight hours well it's
just absolutely mind-blowing to me and I
think that's my favorite part about
Ecuador so that's my questions that I
get all the time cool alright so one of
the questions that John sent me was what
is my favorite insect so here's my
favorite insect my favorite insect is
and work in mantis and it's one of my
favorites because it's pink and I mean
pink insects are awesome but also it has
this really interesting biology called
aggressive mimicry where as you can tell
it kind of looks like a flower it looks
like an orchid and the orchid mantis
will sit not on the flowers so we
thought we just assumed that it was
camouflaged and would just sit on these
flowers and would don't eat things it
turns out that the organ mantis it's
away from the flowers it's it on a leaf
all by itself and because of its shape
and color it attracts the pollinators to
it so it's using its own body as bait
and when the pollinators get too close
the Mantis grabs them out of the air and
keeps them so it's this idea called
aggressive mimicry and I just think it's
so cool so it's like a pretty pink
insect and he's like badass that's my
favorite in a quiz for you guys
I'm gonna make John play as well so if
you guys want to jump in the comments
and try and guess which of these insects
has complete metamorphosis so if you
remember from John's presentation two
weeks ago and complete metamorphosis is
will talk about a little bit later but
specifically when you go through like a
people stage so John you have I think
you can get it based on process of
elimination but I think be you think do
you complete metamorphosis yes are you
sure about that no I do have any guesses
in the comments is it so what are these
bugs first of all like yeah well if I
tell you what they are they don't give
them it'll give it away so I want to see
if you have any guesses before let's see
we got Brent says D know we got a or D
yeah someone else says the dragonfly is
that a dragon fire is that a damselfly
it's actually damselfly but yeah so what
is the kata and the top I guess in the
top left would be the cicada right no
but is actually closely related to the
cicada so like good job cuz it's like
it's like a weird topical insects that
we don't even have in in the States
so close relations a good job not mine
nice we got we got a DC and F okay so
I'll give you guys the answer it is
actually see is a wingless mom yeah
the females in this group are are
wingless so here's the tricky one the
top one is a type of plant hopper fairly
close to you ladies of gates a cicada is
B is a cockroach see is this fault incra
worm and D is a damselfly and I bring up
the phone
because I get this question all the time
like what is this bug because if you
live in the south eastern United States
you will be seeing a lot of these really
seen they come out in the fall as their
name might suggest and a lot of people
are like what is this weird wingless
like cockroaches looking thing it's
actually a wingless moth so now when
someone asks you'll have the answer okay
nice so I'm going to briefly go over the
types of development I know John went
over it like two weeks ago but we're
going to be diving into it a little bit
more specifically than what than what
John did so first we have incomplete
metamorphosis which is like an umbrella
term for a couple of these more specific
development types of important to be
showing you so the first is a metabolize
development which I know John talked
about but if you didn't remember or
didn't show up to his his talk two weeks
ago I'm a metabolize development is just
basically the baby and the adult look
exactly the same the only difference is
that the adult is bigger pretty much but
if you looked at you like oh yeah that
is definitely a baby of that thing over
there on the second line which John
specifically mentioned I think you
mentioned a messy bug or maybe the
milkweed bug yeah yeah what oh yeah
whatever sucks and this is Carl metallus
development and this is when the like
after you have the egg stage you have
nips and the nips basically look like
the adult but you start growing in
things in the nihms like wing pads and
if you are like a katydid and then you
have like a really long over posit or
and that will also start growing in so
it's kind of like a mikelis and the fact
that you know your nips kind of look
like you're adults but you can actually
see the development of these of these
adult parts like wings and genitalia
over positives all that kind of stuff
okay someone someone just asked so what
a cockroach be a metabolize it is not a
metallus it is part of a timeless
because baby cockroaches don't have
their wings yet so you'll see the wings
like you'll see the link pass
churches are kind of hard cuz they're
like all brown
but if you actually like picked one up
and got a good look at you would see
that the wings start slowly growing in
my metabolism
enough reserved for your like very
primitive insects that don't have wings
so things like silver fish micro
Carinthia which are jumping bristle
tails and just a small bug that I'm sure
you've never noticed in your life so
yeah and I get a lot of questions for a
metabolite
oh well don't spiders or scorpions have
a metabolism element and like they would
but they're not insects so they don't
get a fancy need okay yeah I don't know
all right so then the third type of
incomplete metamorphosis is heavy
metabolism and this is like your
damselflies and your dragonflies where
the nymph or Nyad stage because like
sometimes water insects are called my
ads because entomology is terrible in
lifting me names but basically the
nymphal stage looks completely different
than the adult stage and they occupy two
different habitats and that's going to
be important a little bit later when we
start talking about you know evolution
kind of more generally but the important
thing to note here is that coming to
tackle us even though the nymphs or nine
stage and the adult stage look very
different there is no pupa stage and
that's why they are in the incomplete
metamorphosis so that now we go to
complete development and a fancy term
for that that is holo metabolize all
these fancy turns and this is when you
have four different life stages you have
the egg you have the larva or
caterpillar and you have the pupa or if
you're a butterfly in a moth and it's
called a chrysalis and a cocoon
respectively because the pretty insights
get fancier names and you have the
adults so like again the main difference
between is having the catalyst and the
hole of metabolism that
polemical us always has of people stage
in the middle but there's more because
you wouldn't expect biology to be easy
would you so I'd be reading
okay alright so typically in holo
Metellus insights this is a slide it's a
shame that you know there's other things
besides butterflies like go through this
development and you have the eggs and
then you have the larvae but the larvae
molds like the larvae needs to get
bigger and molds as it's eating and the
larvae basically all look the same just
the larger larvae look larger than the
smaller ones like that's basically the
only difference and in most whole of
metabolism insects but then there's like
these beautiful beasts the undercoating
this thing called hyper metamorphosis
where it is they hold on the Tablas
insect because it has the egg and larvae
and pupae and an adult stage however be
based on its biology it will have two
different types of larval stages so
here's a blister beetle they spend as
soon as the egg is laid then when they
hatch they have this kind of mobile form
some-some blister beetles attack
grasshopper eggs some are actually
parasitic on these so they have this
really mobile stage where they're like
attaching looking for their prey that
kind of that kind of deal and then the
larvae will go into a second third or
fourth form depending on what it's doing
a service is called like a scarab form
and it basically just looks like a grub
that you would expect it to this is when
it's like dropped off and it's
completing the rest of its development
and just means kind of like it's this
doesn't need to be as mobile so it goes
into this weird other like not quite as
a mobile stage and it's the temperature
and everything is right it'll go
directly into the pupae if not some of
them go into these other weird larval
stages where they overwinter and just
kind of go into a sort of hibernation so
these are all larvae there are different
types of larvae but they're all larvae
and then eventually you'll get the pupae
which which is why this is technically
hold metabolize development so pretty
crazy these aren't the only insights
that do this you can see this in
mantis flies there's some good group of
insects called the twisted winged
insects that do this so it's like really
extreme whole metabolise development
okay okay my question there is so they
start out they all start out as the same
looking larvae but didn't they have to
or they had two larval forms and go into
is it one or the other or they go
through all those except for on the left
side here and if the temperature is
right below directly from that weird
fast thing straight up into the pupae if
the temperature isn't quite right or it
needs to go into die pods or something
then it'll go through like weird other
stages to handle winter and then it will
go into the pupae some someone asked why
are insects so complicated yeah only has
four hundred million years of evolution
so join entomology because like we don't
have answers to anything so yeah okay
this is basically all of the all of the
rest of the picture of development and
metamorphosis so here we're just going
to be looking at the number of orders of
each development so there are me and
companion who you ask
like 32 to 36 orders of insects um most
orders of insects several orders are
immature I guess John is probably talked
about kina phylum class order and so
orders are just are just groups of
insects that belong together based on
certain characteristics so like all
insects have six legs an order for
example would be a beetle like all
beetles have that really hard that hard
exoskeleton and my our hard shell and by
all I mean almost all of them except the
ones that lost them but they're still
Beals is complicated but then you look
at it beetle you can tell it's a beetle
and if you look at a dragonfly you can
tell it's a dragonfly
that's like order groups and so most
orders have this poorer metabolize
development which is you know you slowly
grow and the wings you slowly grow into
the
Tahlia the nips and needles kind of look
the same however if we look at these
development types by species the
complete metamorphosis like blows them
out of the water like beetles themselves
have 350,000 species at least I think
we're almost up to up to 400,000 species
butterflies are 108 or five slides in
moths are 180 thousand species and so we
have what we call the big four so here's
the estimated number of species
worldwide by all the different types so
on the bottom you're seeing all the
different type orders and then on the
y-axis you're seeing how many species
there are wicked as managed insects or
is this like all of what effect yeah and
say if you look over here to the right
you'll see that Colie approach are the
beetles Hymenoptera which are wasps bees
and ants let the doctor which are
butterflies and moths and dick drot
which are flies are what we call the big
four and they are the most species
diverse insects that we have and they
all are polar metabolites are complete
metamorphosis development so that yeah
it's crazy right um I'm not going to
leave us into this question of why we
think so
how many metabolize development
something goes you just pretty quickly
I'm so here you're a metallus insects
this um this is from a science paper
that came out in 2014 so really like
it's the most recent genetic clade that
we have for insects so a metabolism is
kind of start at you know your very very
primitive insects you'll get having the
tablets scattered around and I mean the
Tablas is really interesting because it
involved several times and so the
dragonflies and mayflies probably
evolved it in one chunk the stoneflies
evolved it on their own and cicadas
actually evolved it on their own as well
so you have a lot of conversion
evolution you metabolize in
which are the ones that again their news
and their adults live in completely
different habitats and I'm here yeah a
quick quick question someone asked if
you study crustaceans at all and no you
don't a topic for entomology I know they
hey they actually are they there's this
there's this theory called the sister
group are it's two insects are
crustaceans but we're like yeah marine
biologist you guys get the crops we only
study like terrestrials I'm actually
curious I know that most like crabs and
stuff they go through a larval state
that is active and is its own thing just
fairly similar to metamorphosis but I
they it seems like they're they would be
more they gradually develop into the
like adult crab form so they don't they
don't go and crabs don't have a
chrysalis form know that yeah yeah so
there's this sigh in entomology just how
crustaceans dominated the oceans insects
dominated the land so recently and sex
is kind of like the terrestrial
crustaceans but yeah we we don't study
we don't study crustaceans there's like
gills and stuff and like live underwater
you don't handle those lots of insects
have guild right thank you I'm not a
whole time but some do I like plea cops
which are the stoneflies giant I have
about 2,000 species in them join one and
damselflies also about two to three
thousand mayflies have a thousand so mom
and it's it's the larval state in
dragonflies that are a quadrant in Fulci
yes and then there are tricopter
char the caddisflies and they do go
through complete metamorphosis and their
larval and people stages underwater and
some Dobson flies as well
is a mosquito there's a mosquito go
through full metamorphosis it does yeah
so the mosquito larvae and the pupae are
underwater yeah do they it is a
miniscule ever have gills no no actually
I baked this is why so many thoughts
okay
so inside skills are very sensitive to
changes in the water that's why we use
things like mayflies like stone flies
like cata slides that have gills as
water quality indicators because if
there's any chemicals or the kind of
oxygen in the water they basically just
died they're very sensitive
I'm mosquito larvae they can live in
just about any garbage dumps because
they don't use gills they have like
their breathing tubes are there like a
hole at the end of there but where they
do all their respiration they swim up to
the surface and they have these little
hairs that come off the end of the
abdomen and like put make like a little
hole in the surface of the water through
surface tension and breathe oxygen like
surface oxygen Wow so that's why they
can't live in basically any garbage dump
unfortunately unfortunately but legged
their biology because oh yeah so here we
are with the poor open Tolleson sites
again these are the winds that I they
slowly develop their wings and they
slowly develop their genitalia over time
and then finally you have all of your
plate metamorphosis or whole limitless
insects and so you can actually see kind
of like the gradation on on this
timeline of blending things evolve
complete metamorphosis is not only the
most biodiverse
but also the most recent in in evolution
and we think that Finn's like we think
that honey Metellus evolved more than
once that's kind of like a symbol that
it was not but like a suggestion that it
was effective because it evolved more
than once and hole in the table so it
was a huge it's just so bio diverse that
we also use that as an indicator showing
that like it was an effective strategy
I think that these two are particularly
effective because the nymphal stage or
the larval stage is is not competing
with the adults you're in two completely
different habitats if you're a dragonfly
like your your niya your nymph is in the
water and you are an aerial predator if
you are a butterfly your calculators
eating leaves your adult is drinking
nectar and eating pollen if your cicada
you're a nymph is underground eating
plant SAP in the fruits your adult is up
in the trees
some don't feed but some do trains of
plants out at the top of the trees in
the canopy and so basically you
eliminate competition with your
offspring this is why your parents take
you out of the house to go to college
because they're like tired of sharing
with you so basically what we think is
going on here and we think it's so
successful because you eliminate
competition with your own species yeah
and sorry you said that Hemi metabolize
evolve multiple times possibly yeah yeah
habilis once yeah it's all one straight
shot yes yeah so from from the bees the
butterflies that's they have they have a
common ancestor that was going through
full metamorphosis yes but it's back
there somewhere it's somewhere in this
node here's the paper you but yeah they
they evolved somewhere in the Permian
and it's kind of like your so it depends
I so this paper is the most recent so
this is one that we're going office but
we've seen Hymenoptera where we're one
of the first ones or some ancestor to
Hymenoptera but did we what we thought
was the timeline for insects like this
paper kind of threw some of it in a mix
so we're still working on the genetics
we're still working on when different
insects evolved and the reason why our
fossil and Malin
earlier paleontological entomology is
such a mess is because insects are not
dinosaurs and so most people go into
alien ecology to study dinosaurs and not
insects so feel free if you are
interested yeah go into entomology and
like fossil entomology well i-i've just
been impressed by how poor the if I'm
trying to look something up about
insects online I I just can't find it so
not not only are not only is entomology
understudied it like in the fossil
record but it's also under information
about it is under distributed online you
have to go to a library to really learn
about bugs
yeah people just don't you know the
Wikipedia articles are horrible still
and they're not horrible but they're
they're lacking there's a lot of people
should be more interested in bugs
they're amazing because that exact
reason and said you have any questions
feel free to look up the blog ask an
entomologist on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and an actual website and
eveness send us questions and we did
that because like we feel like we have
to unlock this literature because even
if you look up these terms just on
google like you'll get like
contradictory information for the terms
that i'm even showing you today like
these terms come from my taxonomy
textbook and they are like really well
noted online um so if you have any
questions about bugs you want reliable
information feel free to message me
personally or feel free to message
asking technologists yeah we got a
question speaking of asking an
entomologist we had a question and I
think this is good because you know we
just talked about kind of the reasons
for studying insects Jay asked if there
are any extract from insects that we use
medicinally uh yeah actually we're just
starting to study that like indigenous
people especially in like South America
have said that ant stings helps things
help with things like arthritis and now
we're actually starting to look into
those so a lot a lot of venom doesn't
technically hurt you like not from a
biological perspective it's not doing
damage to your tissue but it is
interfering with the pain receptors so
especially the potassium ion channels is
it is a main one that insect venom uses
and so by understanding how these
chemicals like this venom is affecting
the pain receptors in humans and we're
now starting to look at maybe how the
copy these these chemicals to actually
block those pain receptors and right now
people are looking into centipede venom
as well that's still very very new so
come back like four years maybe I'll
have a better answer for you and by the
way it shout-out to Shannon all right
sorry that looks like it looks like
that's all the questions so far again
folks if you have a question you want to
definitely make sure that we see send
that as a super chat but yes I'm trying
to go through everything here as best I
can
- oh is there any hormone other than
June or moan controlling metamorphosis
oh my goodness yes I actually have one
on my youtube channel about birth and
development and it talks about all of
the different hormones that go into it
in diesem is one and that that's like
the precursor that tells insects that
they should start shedding their
exoskeleton and then in in Colo
metabolize insects it's the same
hormones but it's the levels at which
she finds them which flip-flop which
tell the insect to go into these
different stages and juvenile hormone
actually
insects in their larval state for like
ever so for holo metabolism insects you
actually need to stop the production of
juvenile hormone to get into the the
chrysalis stage and that's all of our
insecticides work actually is it's a
synthetic of various species specific
juvenile hormone and it keeps them in
their larval state forever so they can
never grow up reproduce oh that's
brilliant
so does that hurt them or they just live
out their lives as like happy little
children no these live out their lives
it's like having a little children and
eventually there's like dying and a lot
if you go to a pet store and you ever
seen like the super meal worms like
that's what a super mutant wimps are
they're just I've fed juvenile hormone
so they get being in fat and never
complete their development into a beetle
so here is your new stuff yeah so I
whole YouTube video on my channel
youtube.com slash sidekicks about growth
in development and it goes through each
of the hormones it goes through
different experiments so so you can see
how we figured out what these hormones
were doing there were like crazy
experiments in the 50s where they like
took caterpillars like took caterpillars
they took the head of one category cut
off the rest of it so that head to the
pupa of a next one and made like a ring
of pupa and because the brain is
releasing all the hormones and all the
blood just like flows in between all of
these so Koopa together or some
caterpillars actually all counselors and
no they were actually sewn pupae they
all emerged as as moths even though
their momma together from one head yeah
so that YouTube video has all these
crazy experiments like just in time for
Halloween so how do we find that YouTube
video at youtube.com slash side legs in
the physiology section under your
answers Griffin development okay
youtube.com for /sy bugs s CI bugs
yes for YouTube channel also put a link
to that in the video description after
this is all over so people can can find
that pretty easy yeah excellent
yes we had we had one more question
what's the earliest known bee species in
the fossil really is known bee species
in the fossil record that sounds like a
question for my phone earliest the
fossil well my phone is googling that we
can talk about because this was one of
the questions how many times did flight
evolve and once about 300 million years
ago and our oldest wing fossil is of a
mayfly or at least the precursor to the
main classic here's the actual the
actual fossil which doesn't look like
that much so here's a drawing of
something that looks slightly more
insect like and this was a precursor to
our modern-day mayfly Wow Wow
all right so just just to be clear with
everybody when we find something in the
fossil record that's nice and develop
like this that means it's actually
existed significantly longer before it
was found because the fossil record
doesn't show us all the animals that
live in an environment the fossil record
shows us the animals that have already
dominated a particular environment
because fossilisation is such a rare
process the only way to become a fossil
usually is to be a super super common
animal so when we find when we say it
you said it's 300 million years ago yeah
yeah that that would be when these
things started to dominate and again
because the insect fossil record is so
poorly studied it might be way older
than that yeah it's one is one of the
difficulties of paleontological
researches we can find it we can we can
date a fossil pretty well but it's
really hard to tell if it's actually the
first of its kind so insects of all four
hundred million years ago so we think so
you know about 300 million years ago
when we we started getting flight yeah
and the other thing too is like a lot of
these insights like so mayflies even
though they have an excess
it's not very hard like they're very
easy to squish so many many insects like
this then actually leaves those fossils
or leaf fossils very regularly because
they are so soft body
this one must sounded like a mud pit and
so I was like really soft muddy silt
that left this impression alright I got
the answer the oldest be the oldest be
fossil is a hundred million years ago oh
wow yeah so oldest known be we've been
able to identify 100 million years ago
there you go to put that in perspective
like the asteroid killed the dinosaurs
like 65 million years ago so insects are
old yeah alright so a couple other
questions that we got while we're here I
did wings or metamorphosis evolved in
butterflies first and butterflies are
just kind of hanging on to things that
have already evolved so wings evolved
way earlier than complete metamorphosis
did complete metamorphosis evolved
around 200 ish million years ago 250 200
million years ago and wings were 300
million years ago but there is an
interesting note there's like two what
we call it natural groups in entomology
one is Terry Coto it just means wings
and it's all the things that are linked
all the things that are linked are in
one chunk like one evolutionary line and
then like further NASA of these I this
thing called me opera which are also all
one group but niara is specifically when
insects got the ability to fold their
wings under their back or over their
back and we think this is one of the
other reasons why insects could really
diversify because if you can protect
your wings if you can fold them under
your back you can make that top wing
like beetles harder and that opens up
all these new niches for you like you
can climb in your logs you can fit under
rocks you can fit inside other animals
like um in life
dragonflies can't fold their wings over
their back they're just stuck out
sideways
is a
wiser stuck-up upright so if you're in
your environment like they're just
getting hit all the time so the knee
after that was like a big evolutionary
change that allowed a specialized muscle
to hold their wings under the back I'm
not and again all of the yatra are one
are one solid group as well okay so
something interesting to point out here
is that by default bugs have four wings
and a lot of a lot of bugs have lost
their second pair of wings and in the
case of beetles the top wing evolved
into a cover for their bottom wings so
that that if you look at a beetle they
have like this shell that opens up and
then their wings come out and then they
fly around with these two little shell
things sticking out the sides the AVA
tablet insects never had wings they're
like their own really weird prehistoric
group and then and then after you get
Terry goodness it starts with your like
Maine flies and dragonflies so after
them if you see things like lice or
fleas that don't have wings is because
they secondarily lost them because of
their habitat
mainly parasitic insects lose their
wings or really small insects lose their
wings or even high altitude insects lose
their wings Wow
yeah we certainly saw that moth that has
no wings which is really good yeah
exactly and that's because the female
doesn't need to fly the male does all
the work
finds her maids and then promptly dies
yet now I seem to remember there being
debate about what body structure evolved
into wings and insects yeah is that that
still a debate or is it okay yeah
some people think it was legs some
people think it was like extensions off
the thorax
we don't know study the fossil record
that we need help with smiley face yeah
yeah and
yeah okay so then how many times in
violence vs. involving incites and this
is where it gets pretty complicated so
complete metamorphosis has only evolved
once and this timing metabolism old a
couple times new convergent evolution
but there's like this mystical creature
in here called the thrips and they have
neither heavy metabolism nor holo
metabolize development they're like this
weird hybrid in the middle because
nothing's easy so here in the lifecycle
of this rips you have the eggs you have
the first instar they're called larvae
and pupae but we'll talk about why
they're not exactly larvae nor exactly
Cupid but also why we don't have a
better need for them the pupae at the
pro pupa and pupil stage actually do
this underground and so just like you
had honey metabolizer a hole in the
table insects the different life stages
are occupying different niches um but
it's not it's not technically :
metabolize development and why so if you
remember so like how is this crazy thing
different than this hyper metamorphosis
that I'm showing you earlier which is a
true type of full of metabolize
development and basically there are very
specific things that are happening
inside the larva and inside the pupa of
whole amitabha's insects that you are
not seeing in the thrifts even though it
has is very similar you're not has this
very similar looking lifecycle so how do
we make adult bits I know John talked a
little bit about this well he talked a
lot about this two weeks ago we're just
gonna do a quick recap so inside larval
whole of metabolites are complete
metamorphosis insights you have
specialized tissue called imaginal discs
which later give rise to the important
adult bits of the insect like wings like
legs like antennae like eyes and these
are specialized tissues that you can
only find in complete metamorphosis
insects and here's a video of
actually please for you guys it's
playing on my end um yeah yeah nice so
this is a video done by my friend Aaron
Pomerance I could no Studios like this
is his Instagram is next-generation
next-gen scientists they have removed
the imaginal disc of the four wing here
and so you can actually see the
development of the hind wing through
through the chrysalis and this is really
important because I'm inside chrysalis
like all of this development is
happening internally so that's why
you're heavy with tablets insights are
technically different and they don't
have a pupil stage but also all of their
development is normal external
development and here you hear it's
really cool you can actually like see
inside the wing he specifically studies
colors so that's why he did this video
but you can see how all of this
development of the wings is happening
inside the insect and that's another
reason why these holy metallus insects
are different than like these serfs or
these other insects that have that that
have similar looking lifestyles so you
have you see they have these imaginal
discs that are only found in houma
tablets insects and you have all of this
development happening on the inside and
also in holo metropolis insects you have
a great most are making it not all of
the insect but a lot of it turns into
goop so here are some of the things that
stay the same inside the chrysalis you
have the tracheal system and the gut
which mainly stay the same so hearing it
and writing up the guts wait the wing
development you have in green and then
the breathing to use of the tracheal
system in blue so this is the first day
of the chrysalis and it basically has
all of the same structures at the larval
caterpillar wood and so as you go today
for you start seeing a reduction of the
gut this is reflective of how the how
the caterpillar is eating leaves now
you're adults and eating nectar so you
need a smaller cut I
winds are starting to develop and then
you also get these more extensive
breathing tubes because not any more
oxygen to power flight and this is day
13 when the with the product less about
to emerge and you can see how intense
and that that tracheal system becomes a
he'll reduce that god is and we do know
that some of the central nervous system
also stays intact it's not in this bit
kind of x-rated but there are
experiments even trained caterpillars as
larvae and they remember that training
with their adults and so the three
things that really make the these two
groups different is all in the larval
stage so you have these imaginal discs
that are only found in the whole of
Metropolis insects and you have all of
this development which is completely
internalized so if you look at the
strips on the left side here you can see
like in the drawing the little legs and
little like wing pads are still external
just like they would be in your
damselflies or dragonflies whereas in
the hole on the tile is insect that's
all like kept up and all that
development is happening on the inside
and you're having a lot of you're having
a lot of your muscle tissue and all of
that being completely reconstructed from
scratch so though that's why these are
different even though like the thrips
kind of looks like it should be a whole
metabolizing superficially there are
some internal physiological things that
are different and these are all my
references so you know that I'm not a
lying sack of crap
thank you I'd be really happy to take
any questions at this point
all right cool so we got one question
about grasshoppers yes
grasshoppers turn to look as where's
that fit in development they're there
they are adults already right hey yes
that is like more we aren't quite sure
about all of that biology so like again
if you want to study ontology feel free
to study locusts because we need help
it seems to be as the insects are
growing up lots of grasshoppers in
general are gregarious which means they
hang out in groups when they're young
and locusts are like an extreme version
where they have that as adults as well
and are super aggressive in what they
can eat and that they swarm together and
it seems to be like some sort of
environmental shift that triggers that
development during during the stirring
like the growing up stages of the
grasshopper
and we're not sure what environmental
things trigger it we don't know how that
works physiologically we don't there's a
lot we just don't know we're like
basically entomology right now's like
yes
locusts exist and they're weird and
they're a thing and we're working on it
that's awesome
let's see someone asks what are thrips
really need to do dreams are like their
own group they're most closely related
to true bugs which is an awful common
name that they're most closely related
to the knot all right sorry hey Mick
you're angry which are the tree bugs and
but they're their own order they're
their own like magical little unicorns
they're being plant crop pests so that's
why there's a lot of research done on
them yeah someone someone asks again
is there any hormone other than juvenile
hormone controlling metamorphosis and
yeah you said that there's lots of them
right there's one more that I can't
remember
phtt pH something like that I can't
remember but it's in my it's in the
presentation I did like four years ago
look it up yeah and then to Oteri's
something hormone the pituitary
something hormone yeah
someone says for bugs that have
different stages to not compete with
their young why do some young eat their
parents and I didn't know that was the
thing yeah I mean there's some insects
that are just cannibalistic and they'll
just eat whatever they can
it's like happens to be in the same spot
as them like mantis nymphs will eat each
other but I can't really think of an
example where the the larval or the
nymphal stage eats the adult because I
don't know how that would be
particularly possible since the adult is
a lot larger yeah um yeah so if you have
a specific example let me know because I
can't think of one off the top of my
head the let's see someone's asking
about plume moths diplomas have just
four wings or do they have a whole fan
of them no they have four wings that's
what I was talking about really small
insects have a reduction in their wings
and so the plume moth wings has actually
just been reduced into like four little
feathered structures and that's not
uncommon it's not the only group that
has done that again it's a really cool
example of convergent evolution where
pluma moths have done it and there are
there's a little wasp it's like one of
the things the smallest one of the
smallest insects it's called the fairy
fly and it also has like these weird
feather-light wings there's a whole
group of these smallest beetles which
are like two millimeters long 0.2
millimeter like their specs and they
have clothes reduced feathery wings as
well like those beetles are so small
that they don't even have a heart you're
like yeah I'm just gonna like give up
having a heart to be smaller I guess
it's like eventually like you get you
can't fit your internal organs hi yeah
that's that's wild or you just don't
need a heart if you're when your body is
really small you don't need a
circulatory system really because you
all of your cells have enough access to
outside you know chemicals basically
it's just a tube and it's open on both
sides and the heart is in the front and
then there's a thing called the dorsal
vessel that runs along the length of the
abdomen and so the dorsal vessels in the
thorax and it runs along the length of
the body and the doors the heart like
pumps and it basically does like takes
squishy blood that's inside the inside
from the back and shoots it up towards
the brain so let's say how does like
nutrient cycling mmm it's not racing
things to work though yeah I mean well
you know we have really complicated
circulatory systems but it's because
we're giant animals yeah and if you look
at our ancestors they had really simple
they were small and they had it lived in
the ocean and they had a really simple
circulatory systems and that's I mean
that's actually the evolution of
complexity in the circulatory system
allowed animals start getting bigger and
bigger you know we we had to be small
before we evolved better circulatory
systems it's I haven't seen this
question here today but is there it
because of this simple circulatory
system and insects does that limit the
size the body size that an insect can be
yes so there's a couple couple
limitations
I actually just answered them I do live
videos on my Twitter and periscope as
well there's a couple of reasons why you
can't get giant insects anywhere one of
them we think is because there was just
more oxygen in the atmosphere and so
when you have this really simple it's
not just a simple circulatory system
they also have what's called an open
respiratory system and so like basically
there are the holes on the outside of
the body that run along the thorax and
the abdomen and these little holes like
air diffuses in and then there's there's
tubes it's basically just a series tubes
and the tubes like branch off into
smaller tubes and branch off into
smaller tubes and branch off into
smaller tubes eventually some of these
tubes are only like the width of a cell
or the diameter of a cell and so their
entire breathing is done through the
future again it's not particularly
efficient so one of the ideas is that
yeah they're just wanted in in the
atmosphere before and so you can support
larger insects and then you have the
asteroid that hit and everything just
kind of got smaller
mainly because thanks for starving to
death and big animals couldn't support
themselves with not a lot of food so
then there is like everything just got
smaller and now there isn't really a big
evolutionary push towards large animals
for whatever reason especially within
sites it's hard to get that big again
there's less oxygen in the air but also
you have but also like when the insect
is doing its development it has to molt
out of its old exoskeleton and during
that molting process it's very it's very
weak the exoskeleton hasn't hardened yet
it needs to have the stock excess elgyn
to pull out of the old one and just wait
there for anywhere between 20 minutes
and two hours for things to dry and so
if you're too big you collapse under
your own weight and and so that that's
not great
even you still see this today Lee even
with mantis breeders they'll talk about
how the humidity isn't quite right and
if the humidity isn't quite right like
the Mantis is don't mold properly and
they'll get crushed and under their own
weight and severely injured - also dead
yes I I would like you to show us that
awesome collection of insects you have
behind you and while you're getting that
not off the wall I want to talk real
quickly about you know this was going to
be today's presentation but Nancy got
ahold of me and said that she can
actually do this interview today and
this has been amazing thank you so much
this was real
when I talk about insects when I teach
about insects I am like basically
everything that you've ever heard me say
dear audience about insects
Nancy taught me so she is my expert on
insects and then you know whatever I can
glean I don't actually have any
entomology books so I have to look at in
biology textbooks and online and as I
mentioned earlier there's not very much
information good information available
online as you'd mentioned some of it
contradicts the other stuff even like
the Wikipedia articles contradict each
other I mean there is stuff I mean thank
you to all the people that have produced
you know on but but it you know it's
it's not hasn't been perfected yet yeah
so next week I will be talking about
this amazing paper called 40 years of a
new troe evolution and I've got a link
in the video description where you can
actually download that and read it ahead
of time if you want it gets a little bit
technical if you're not already used to
RNA evolution experiments or the idea of
RNA replication I've got a video called
what is the RNA world hypothesis it's an
animation that I made for my other
channel for stated clearly and check out
that video first and actually homework
assignment for next week if everybody
could watch this what is the RNA world
hypothesis ahead of time you'll be
everything will make more sense to you
and next week's talk but yeah we're
gonna go over this this paper 40 years
of in vitro evolution and for those that
aren't really used to reading scientific
literature most of what we find in the
scientific literature is you know people
will do experiments and then they'll
write about those experiments and their
their conclusions might not be super
solid and this is how scientists present
their research to other scientists as
through the scientific literature the
same will happen if someone makes an
observation if an inch
just makes a unique observation I'll
write about a little document that put
it into a paper and then scientists will
debate about it and go back and forth
you know sometimes for years in the
literature so normally when you when
you're reading a scientific literature
you're not really reading solid
conclusions you're reading people
forming those conclusions you're
actually seeing scientists in real time
forming conclusions but every once in a
while assign it people will assign
someone in a field to write an overview
of research and that's what this is this
is an overview of 40 years of in vitro
evolution experiments and so he just
goes through here and talks about some
really neat experiments were doing on
the evolution of genes in the test tube
in vitro as in you know in glass in the
test tube and this is really really
really cool this paper is amazing not
only have have we evolved really
interesting you could almost call them
organisms but they're just made out of
RNA in the test tube we've actually
evolved medicines and the test tube like
I mean RNA is replicating evolving on
their own and the the researchers have
you know sort of you could say kind of
trained them they tweak with the
environment and have the molecule adapt
to that environment until the molecule
is able to do procedure that we want it
to do inside the human body
we actually evolved a medication with
RNA it's absolutely amazing anyway we'll
talk about that next week
let's just end today's show by having
you show us your insect look in there
yeah let me get it oh but you know
that's not necessarily the case there
are so many examples at forensic air and
insects there's even one it's called the
giant water bug and the mail actually
carries the eggs on his back so plus one
for eternity fraternity is there's the
North American carrion beetles will
actually like they get a mouth I could
get a dead
they bury it they lay their eggs on the
dead thing they stay in the Burrow and
coat adenosine with antibacterial saliva
and communicate with the larvae until
the larvae pupae and then emerge from
the Burrow and the parents actually die
down there is one of the most extreme
examples of parental care in the animal
world let alone just insects so lots of
examples of parental care super cool
yeah and then besides fruit flies what
other insects are used to study
evolution and lots of insects one of the
major ones was the silkworm moths
because it's big and especially in the
fifties like when our molecular
techniques weren't amazing in our
physiological techniques for anything we
couldn't get a lot of stuff out of the
bugs Bombyx mori which is the which is
the silkworm caterpillar it's just huge
so there's just a lot more sample to use
a lot of logic metric work is it's also
done in them um yeah and any really fast
reading insect yeah exactly
all right so here here's one in my
collections this even from Ecuador I'm
the person who had them so I want to
talk a little I hope this collection
first I'm not usually the person to have
dead bugs in my wall and someone else
had them and he was going back to Canada
it is a legal trance to move insects
without permits like this and so they
would either be thrown out or sold to
someone else
and I got him the day he was leaving for
Canada and I was like oh I can use them
to it for educational purposes so that's
why I have effects on my wall so cool so
here we have the beetle we trying it the
reflection anyway so this is as you can
tell it's large and so these like kind
of orange things under here these kind
of orangey things in your tier are the
wings and then the four wing has been
hardened into this hard shell and so the
beetle shell is actually modified for
wing and yeah
and I actually did on my youtube channel
as well I have a video series about well
it just explains and I talked about how
the Beatles basically have self-folding
origami to get the wings back under
under their shelf so if you don't need
to channel if you're interested about
like how beetles get the wings under
their shelf how they're folded then that
the thing that you can finally need to
channel as well so when a star all
exoskeletons made of how do you say it
Titan okay yes yes and other other
molecules in there they're used instead
or along there so the basic excess
skeleton is Payton it's clear that's how
you get the special color and Lucky's
Marco butterflies it's just stacked up
chitin so it's naturally clear and
transparent it's really soft and
flexible and so to make hard insect
exoskeletons you you have a tanning
process called sclera cessation and it's
a compound called sclera tin that is
mixed into the chitin to make it harder
and the worst layers and you have the
darker and harder your exoskeleton is
cool it looks like that's pretty much
the questions I wanted to just before
you leave oh it's already 11 10 but um
just like 5 more minutes here you have
really interesting career path because
most people who go into entomology and
that be going into studying pests and
how you know different ways that we can
get rid of pests because but but you
have done something very very different
and if you could kind of explain you
know why you didn't just go into pest
control and then you know what what have
been the struggles because you made your
own way I mean you totally self-made
person there's there wasn't a job
waiting for you that you went to you
built this education
vacation has always been it's so so
important me so we don't even know where
to start so little little young
undergraduate me was like I love bugs I
love them so much they're so pretty
they're gorgeous people are afraid of
them and you know nothing about them I
think that was like the craziest thing
to me and why I actually got into bugs
is what I thought like I was the only
person that was noticing them and too
every time I asked someone they were
like oh it's not that I don't know if
that science doesn't know and I was like
how can science not know like sometimes
science doesn't even know what insects
eat like this blows my mind imagine
going to the Galapagos right you're
going to the Galapagos Islands here with
your guide and the guide is like oh
that's a sea lion and you're like oh
cool what does it eat oh we don't know
what do you mean you don't know
oh that science doesn't know that he's
like what so definitely that doesn't
treat me so much so I was like okay well
I don't want people to be afraid of fun
I love bugs I really want to go into
teaching I always loved information I've
always loved talking to people about how
amazing our world is so then I went to
grad school to see if I liked teaching
and it turns out that I like teaching
and hate research that pretty much is
how it boiled down and I didn't I didn't
want to do pest control like you know
people are like why do you go into
entomology wife entomology field and
mainly it's because insects are our
major competitors for our food our space
and our health and that's why most
people get a technology there's a lot of
money in entomology but you basically
just like study mosquitoes or crop pests
and then learn how to kill them and I'm
like what about all these really
beautiful bugs out there oh you know
nothing about like what they eat like
why don't like them is like the
mysteries of the insect world and so
when I graduated my masters I really had
like no idea what I wanted to do with my
life um like no I just it's like clearly
academia is not for me and I went to
Ecuador and I volunteered in an
eco-lodge
or for two years I was basically seeing
like oh do I like working with the
public is
education something I'm interested in
who I have to be a professor like and I
just loved it like just being just being
in Ecuador and being like hi you know
that thing that you read in textbooks
like there it is Alexis right there it's
like the coolest thing to me like oh did
you hear about like the rainshadow
effect on like the Magic School Bus
which was like the first time I heard
about the raincoat effect yeah we're
going to drive through it so you can
actually see the change one side of the
mountain and the other and yeah that's I
got to this and then I was like I want
to keep doing this I don't want like so
any possible way to make that make it a
reality it's like I'm gonna work on my
youtube channel and doing my videos for
periscope eating podcast and then
started doing tours just - just so I can
keep just telling people how beautiful
and amazing and incredible and
interesting insects are yeah
well I'm I'm really glad that you're
doing this because you're doing amazing
job I usually when I google something
about insects something you loot pops up
yeah I was like I was actually looking
for the dragonfly so that way I could
get a nice picture and literally the
YouTube video that I made was like the
first one last maybe there's a couple
questions to hear but someone asked if
spiders used chitin as well yes yes so
actually is conserved from in all you
know I'm gonna say all arthropods I mean
that's a lot so like 99.9% of our
throats but shrimp also have kind so
shrimp crabs spiders scorpions these
beetles they always hang and so they're
vertebrate equivalent to Titan is
keratin so like in structural color
which is like
all these marks of butterflies are
really really shiny and pretty and
that's a structural that's like chitin
built up in specific ways to reflect
light
hummingbirds do the same thing it's just
keratin stacked up in specific ways to
reflect light so chitin is kinda like
the arthropod equivalent of you know
vertebrate keratin yeah keratin is what
our fingernails are made of yeah
callus all right
well any any last things that you just
have to tell us before we sign off here
yes definitely visit Nancy in Ecuador
like I said she put together an amazing
tour for me and my buddies and just you
know we only had three days and it was
yeah I changed my life who's awesome
just so many cool things to see there
and just once you'd realize that bugs
are so fascinating they are everywhere
this for me it was you know the first
realization I had about this was when I
was younger like realizing how amazing
birds are we just ignore them all the
time but birds are amazing and they're
everywhere insects are amazing and
they're everywhere and if you start
looking at them you can you will never
be bored once you start studying insects
and once you start studying birds
because there's always something amazing
to see you don't you don't have to have
a you not to watch documentaries about
it you just go outside and observe for
yourself it's so cool
that's this field of entomology so thank
you Nancy
this was wonderful and thank you to
everybody who's watching
yeah make sure to like this video helps
the YouTube ranking go up higher when
this is posted online and you can
continue to ask questions in the
comments and I'll be monitoring those
and I'll probably write Nancy over in
next week I could
we answer a couple of those questions
there too so again to find Nancy tell us
all the places where we can find you
online YouTube site legs and Instagram
as side dot bugs because someone stole
it from me yeah jerks so that's s CI as
in science side bugs we we also got into
way we got one her question question is
that
cockroaches compared to the kidneys
rivers no fat bodies are like our fat
storage they were almost the same the
Mount
pinky and two bills which are attached
to the which are attached to the
digestive system are like our kidneys
and that's where they do water
reabsorption and passed poops and I also
have a video about that on my youtube
channel
it's the physiology section and it's
just like physiology and insects and
inside that video there's like a time
linked to the digestive system so it's
in there awesome thank you this is great
I think keratin is a protein but chitin
is a mixture of protein and carbs yeah
it's chitin isn't isn't a protein it is
actually a a polysaccharide so it's like
a big sugar molecule it's more I can
tell like cell walls and plants because
it's a sugar molecule I made that
mistake when I did for I did in my first
video i exoskeleton backs analyse it was
a protein it's almost like are you sure
it's not are they are they actually
taking sugars if they get from their
food or does their body make those
sugars I'm sure the response of building
Payton okay you got it to my reading
list you don't know everything about
they don't know everything yeah I
apparently don't know
the sugar expert next time write in a
physiologist physiology like the black
box of insights that I like briefly
dabble in and then actually one more
question that I had I I have heard that
the wax that bees make is actually their
body fat and they excrete is that true
ok cool alright well we're gonna I want
to respect your time here so we're gonna
sign off but this was the awesome this
was really fun yeah well to do it again
sometime so long for now everybody stay
curious plenty with bugs I'll see it